this used to be the home of sergey's
Uncle
he was killed when Russian Forces fight
a rocket that landed on his house
the rocket was very big the explosion
destroyed the structure and the kitchen
my uncle was in the kitchen he was
wounded in the head we pulled him out
and took him to the hospital but it was
too late
Russian forces had taken control of this
Village and stationed themselves at the
local school
from here they fired across the Open
Fields until they were forced out by the
ukrainians but the damage remains
the situation across Southern Ukraine
remains tense
in the city of nicopol shops remain
closed some tried to do business out on
the streets but they live under a
constant deadly and imminent threat
people here are trying to continue life
as normal but nicopol isn't normal we
had to have special accreditation just
to get access to the city we're not
allowed to film freely and we're given a
minder this is a country at War and this
city stands right opposite Russian
forces stationed at Europe's largest
nuclear power plant
authorities here say the Russians fire
from the nuclear plant but Ukrainian
forces can't fire back because of the
risk we're told we cannot film The River
or even go anywhere near it authorities
here are afraid it may give away
Ukrainian positions
the most difficult thing is living
during the constant shelling of Civilian
buildings knowing the fact that the
lives of citizens are at risk also the
fact it can happen at any time
you don't have to go far to find
destroyed buildings
Nikolai shows us the rocket that hit
this apartment block its parts spread
all over the house he tells us
others are trying to do their bit for
the war effort these women gather every
day to sew clothes for the military
this is my hometown I was born here and
I
want to be a part of what is happening
happening with everyone
my home was damaged like many others
also many of my friends have left the
city but I want to stay here
air raid siren goes off and those that
can make their way to bunkers
yeah every night we stay here every day
we have been staying here for two months
we don't want to leave we don't we are
waiting for everything to be over
outside they're growing roses despite
the war the empty parks and the sound of
rockets this hope that they'll be able
to enjoy their Gardens once again
Al Jazeera South Ukraine